Freddie rang gira and Kalia aware agj
have been campaigning for media
inclusion of the Deaf since 2014
according to the latest census there are
more than 30,000 people with hearing
disorders in Rwanda yet few in the
broader public are aware of the
challenges that come with deafness among
us the marginalized into even the
disability movement they are the one who
marginalised others the idea to launch
media for the Deaf came from a research
project on how the media serves disabled
people the findings were alarming with
only one use program available in sign
language deaf people in Rwanda have
extremely limited access to information
what is my contribution or my solution
to that problem that they are facing as
someone who studied journalism and
communication today the media team is
preparing for the next video shoot for
their hashtag sign your name campaign
Diane gasps Humber the minister of
gender and family promotion has agreed
to participate the two activists were
inspired by the success of the recent
ice bucket challenge on social media I
thought it would be easy matter to was
difficult but I was supported and it was
good there's a good experience the
minister also promised further support
for the team and their initiative down
the track
48 celebrities have already taken part
among them local artists
and actors Charaka Grenier Amaury
Montgomery a secretive tidy rajasah
Morocco's the group recently won a young
Rwandan achievers award for their
efforts Freddy is proud that all their
work and commitment has been recognized
use an ICT this came at the right moment
because to give us the spirit of movie :
doing more than because what we are
doing media for the Deaf also plans to
offer sign language workshops for
journalists as well as media training
for deaf people a difficult task because
the young organization is still
struggling financially so far the nine
board members have had to pay all
expenses out of their own pockets but
their success proves that good ideas
don't need much to grow